the John Wick series signature of long
close-up action takes is only possible
because keano Reeves is a performer who
is willing to dedicate countless hours
to mastering any skill that the script
demands in preparation for each John
Wick film Reeves put in months of
full-time training in martial arts
tactical shooting and Precision Driving
as a result the filmmakers have rarely
had to Stage scenes around hiding a stun
actor this has also allowed them to
maintain Reeves's connection with the
audience throughout director Chad
stahelski was Reeves's stunt double for
the Matrix films this means staheli is
intimately familiar with Reeves's
potential and limitations and he
playfully exploits Reeves's habit of
gleefully throwing himself into training
for a film for chapter 2 stahelski
brought in Brazilian Masters the Machado
Brothers to help keano perfect his
jiujitsu and sent him to firearms
training with World Champion Sports
shooter Taran Butler